[Zene]
miért van az hogy a világ sikereinek és
erőforrásainak nagy része mindig egy
kisebbség kezében összpontosul
üdvözöllek a második epizódban ma egy
olyan alapelvről lesz szó amely segít
megérteni hogy a világban a siker és az
erőforrások miért osztanak el mindig
egyenlőtlenül de miért fontos az
alapelvekről beszélni önbecsülést csak
az adhat ha azt tesszük ami helyes és
nem azt ami nép erű vagy elfogadott
igazi elégedettséget valódi belső békét
nem lehet látszatokra építve elérni
lehet hogy kívülről sikeresek vagyunk
mégis belülről az elégedetlenség és az
irigység fog marni minket ahhoz viszont
hogy helyesen cselekedjünk ismernünk
kell az alapelveket beszélnünk kell róla
nem kioktató arrogáns hangnemben mintha
azt mondanánk ennyebenjee ez sem
csinálod jól hanem őszinte törekvéssel
amelyben együtt keressük a helyes utat
hiszen ahogy hanvas béla mondta
mindannyian benne vagyunk a levesben ez
valóban egy közös gondolkodás lehet
hiszen a tervem az hogy egy olyan
közösséget hozzak létre amely együtt ás
egyre mélyebbre és mélyebbre ha tetszik
ez a csatorna akkor csatlakozhatsz a
közösséghez azáltal hogy feliratkozol és
lájkolod ezt a videót ha pedig szeretnél
részt venni a beszélgetésben hagyj egy
kommentet amelyre válaszolni fogok
[Zene]
a következő elvnek egy olyan általános
univerzális alapelvet választottam amely
az életünk minden területén megjelenik
mégis ha nem figyelünk felrá könnyen
szem elül téveszthetjük ez a paretó elv
vagy más néven a 820-as szabály amelyet
gyakran mátfként is emlegetnekfredoetto
gdász 1906-ban alkotta meg ezt a
matematikai képletet arra keresett
választ hogy miért összpontosul a
társadalomban a vagyon nagy része egy
szűk kisebbség kezébe bár maga a képlet
bonyolult és a hétköznapi ember számára
nehezen értelmezhető mégis empirikusan
igazolható egy egyszerű megfogalmazás
szerint a vagyon 80%-a az emberek
20%-ához kerül elsőre talán
igazságtalannak tűnhet de ha mélyebben
megvizsgáljuk ezt az alapelvet
rájöhetünk hogy ha serségesen
megpróbálnánk másképp elosztani a
vagyont majd magára hagynánk a rendszert
néhány évtized alatt újra visszaállna ez
az egyensúly ráadásul ez a
törvényszerűség nem csupán a
vagyonelosztásra érvényes hanem az élet
számos gyökeresen eltérő területére is a
futball világa tipikusan paretó
eloszlást követ ha most megnéznénk a
statisztikákat azt látnánk hogy egy szűk
kisebbség a focisták közül rúgja a gólok
nagy részét ez az arány évről évre
hasonló például 2024-ben rúgott gólokra
de érvényes az elmúlt 50 év
teljesítményére is ez az eloszlás nem
csak az egyéni teljesítményekre igaz
hanem a csapatok szintjén is
megfigyelhető egy szűk kisebbség nyeri a
bajnokságok többségét míg a csapatok
többsége csupán néhány alkalommal ér el
kiemelkedő eredményt a fizetések terén
is ugyanez a helyzet egy kisebbség a
focisták közül annyit keres mint az
összes többi együttvéve tehát nem csak a
vagyonenosztás hanem az egyéni és a
csapatteljesítmény is paretó elosztást
követ nézzük meg néhány olyan példát
ahol az emberi tényezőtől függetlenül
megfigyelhető ez a minta a vulkánok egy
szűk kisebbsége sokkal több aktivitást
mutat mint az összes többi együttvéve a
folyók vízhuzamára is érvényes ez a
törvényszerűség a világ folyói közül egy
szűk kisebbség szállítja a teljes
vízmennyiség jelentős részét a bolygók
mérete sem kivétel a naprendszer nyolc
bolygója közül a szaturnusz és a jupiter
tömege nagyobb mint az összes többi
együttvéve mindezek alapján úgy tűnik
hogy a paretó elv nem csupán emberi
rendszerekben figyelhető meg hanem
egyetemes természeti törvényként is
működik amely az élet minden területére
kihat sokszor igazságtalannak tűnik
hiszen nem esik jól azt hallani hogy egy
természeti törvény szabályozza hogy egy
szűk kisebbség birtokolja a vagyon nagy
részét és hogy ez ellen nincs mit tenni
a kommunizmus megpróbálta ezt az
egyenlőtlenséget eltörölni és valóban
egy ideig el is tudta torzítani ezt az
egyen súlyt de hosszút távon ez nem volt
fenntartható a kommunizmus bukásával a
rendszer újra visszaállt az eredeti
rendjébe hiszen az emberek teljesítménye
is paretto elvet követi ez nem csak az
írók költők és sportolók teljesítményére
igaz hanem az üzletemberekére is és a
termékek sikerességére is figyeljük meg
hogy egy adott
termékkategóriában mindig lesz egy
kiemelkedő termék amelyet annyian
vásárolnak meg mint az összes többit
együttvéve ha például három mosógép
közül kell választanunk és az egyik 567
értékelést kapott 4,6 csillagos átlaggal
míg egy másikat csak 46-an értékeltek
ugyanilyen pontszámmal egy harmadikat
pedig egyetlen ember öt csillaggal akkor
jó eséllyel az elsőt fogjuk választani
hiszen az a legbiztosabb döntés
természetesen előfordulhat ha valaki
több 100 órát tanulmányozza a mosógépek
piacát akkor találhat árértékarányban
jobb választást de egy dolog biztos
általán ágban nem rossz döntés népszerű
terméket választani ha csak nincs időnk
mélyebben elmerülni a kutatásban vagy ha
a választás nem olyan fontos a számunkra
ha pedig a vásárlási szokásainkra is
érvényes a paretto elv akkor nem nehéz
belátni hogy néhány terméket gyártó cég
miért lesz aránytalanul sikeres most
hogy megismertük ezt az elvet felmerül a
kérdés hogyan fordíthatjuk a saját
hasznunkra és hogyan kerülhetjük-e el
hogy az áldozatává váljunk ne keserűen
rázzuk az öklünket az ég felé amiért
igazságtalan a világ hanem használjuk ki
ezt az alapelvet a saját fejlődésünk
érdekében egy praktikus alkalmazása
ennek az elvnek a tanulás folyamatában
figyelhető meg például a könyvek 20%-a
tartalmazza az igazán fontos információk
80%-át ha például a mesterséges
intelligenciát szeretnénk tanulmányozni
az elérhető könyvek online kurzusok
20%ka annyit ér mint az összes többi
együttvéve érdemes tehát egy népszerű
könyvet keresni amelyet sokan méltatnak
ha nem is a legjobbat válasszuk legalább
biztosak lehetünk benne hogy nem hozunk
egy rossz döntést ez a törvényszerűség
magára a könyv tartalmára is igaz az
oldalak 20%-a tartalmazza az információ
80%-át a kérdés csupán az hogy melyik az
a 20% ebben segíthet az intuíciónk is
olvassuk el a tartalomjegyzéket a
bevezetőt esetleg néhány véleményt a
könyvről így már előre tudni fogjuk
miről szól a könyv és mely részletek
tartalmazzák a legfontosabb inf
információkat rengeteg más praktikus
felhasználása van még a paretto evnek
viszont ebbe a videóba most ennyi fért
bele ha részletesebben is érdekel a
paretto elv gyakorlati alkalmazása akkor
csatlakozz a patreon közösségünkhöz ahol
egy exkluzív videóban bontom ki még
részletesebben hogyan növelheted nap
mint nap az eredményességed a paretto
elv segítségével lehetőséged lesz
másokkal is beszélgetni ezekről az
elvekről ha pedig értékesnek találtad
ezt az epizódot és szeretnéd támogatni
ezt a csatornát esetleg személyesen
velem beszélgetni ezekről a témákról
akkor ezt is megteheted ugyancsak a
patreon oldalon